ah all right here we go a lawsuit
scheduled to go to trial next month
pit's a roy a rural california region
against the city of los
angeles and it's reigniting decades-old
tensions so it focused on something we
all need to survive
many take for granted and that's water
los angeles gets half of its water from
the eastern slope of the sierra nevada
for more than a century people there
have battled the city's department of
water and power
over its methods and its environmental
responsibility
and now one county claims the agency is
breaking state law by withholding vital
water deliveries
from a valley it has always irrigated
this comes as climate change shrinks the
snowpack
in these mountains in our continuing
series i on earth jonathan vigliotti
reports
on a new round of water wars raging over
how we share
what's left hundreds of thousands of
people visit the eastern sierra just to
fish along
here on the backside of yosemite
national park
water is life for fishing guide chris
leonard
it's also big business we have to have
lots of it for quality fishing is what
it boils down to
what is the state of water up here right
now it's the american west
you know i mean whiskey's for drinking
and waters for fighting over
the fight playing out here is the stuff
movies are made of
you steal water from the valley ruin the
grazing
the 1974 jack nicholson classic
chinatown
fictionalized a very real early 20th
century water war
it started when famed engineer william
mulholland
and his department of water and power or
dwp
built a system using gravity to deliver
mountain fed water
300 miles south from this remote region
to the growing but water starved city of
los
angeles he bought the land you know he
imposed as a rancher and he bought the
water rights and then he channeled all
the water
down through the owens valley i mean
that's when the water wars really
started
many locals claimed dwp stole the water
but to this day the agency owns almost
500 square miles of land up here along
with the rights to
all the water that flows through it much
of it flows
south to l.a but for decades some of it
dwp diverted to irrigate ranch lands
here in long valley
like the 1600 acres leased by cattle
rancher matt kemp
and his wife maria how much of this
is dependent on water everything you see
if we don't have water to spread out
here none of this
looks like it does now we can take these
if you want
they're one of 10 ranching families
who've worked about 6
000 acres of irrigated land here in long
valley for generations
they say that until recently dwp would
release
billions of gallons of water a year to
keep these fields green
and the cows fed then came a devastating
five-year drought
and the culmination year 2015 dwp came
to us and said
look we're going to dry you guys up it
was a shock
dwp cited the drought as the reason but
three years later when the snowpack in
the mountains had rebounded
they told the ranchers again zero water
would flow to them
my thought was just how are we going to
make it work how am i going to sustain
this how am i going to support my family
the chief of dwp's water system richard
harrick
points out its leases with the ranchers
never guaranteed any water deliveries
but the agency is still committed to
providing them
in 2018 where there was a pretty
moderate snowfall
water to be had and yet none of it for
ranchers
what happened that year well i would say
nothing has changed
year to year except that year it did
change well there's some things that
don't change
number one is the process by which we
determine how much water
we deliver it's really not an equation
it's as much art and science that goes
into that so there's no really one
particular thing that drives
and that is the origin of the water that
we see in the valley
that's right yeah while water is vital
to ranchers
it's also critical to wildlife you
always want to come to where there's
water
jorah fogg is a local biologist with her
eyes
on a particular species on the horizon i
actually see some birds
the bi-state sage grouse is a rare and
unusual bird
its declining population has made it a
candidate for the endangered species
list
all that water spread over the ranch
lands has had a side benefit
an expanded habitat where these birds
thrive
we can't just remove the water
without any notice and without a plan to
protect
the birds wildlife organizations and
ranchers
aren't usual allies i would say that
it's been
really refreshing and i think we've
realized how much
we have in common for the place that we
live and love
ladwp claims it has always set aside
water for sage grouse habitat
they've always gotten water either
incidentally just through the
application water for ranching or when
water is really low will always make a
priority for the sage grass we're
completely and totally at the mercy of
really the snow melts and then there's
the recreational community which fears a
dried-up landscape could drive away
tourists hikers and anglers but it's not
just you that relies on that snowmelt
and the water that comes from
it los angeles how do you compete with
that
how do you compete with dwp yeah you
don't
they own the land some are trying to
compete
in court mono county's lawsuit argues
dwp
must first do a comprehensive
environmental impact review
before making drastic changes to this
ecosystem
like taking away water that's been
provided for decades
and as climate change shrinks the
snowpack and the mountains up here
fights like these back down here will
likely
only get worse what's your message as
you kind of watch this struggle for the
water on friday for snow
favors now right for snow for cbs this
morning jonathan bigliotti
mono county california it's much needed
you need the water
creating these new alliances as they
talk about because this leasing
agreement does not guarantee water
deliveries
we take it for granted we do and it's
you know i find it sort of heartbreaking
to hear somebody
say as they did in jonathan's piece that
they pray for snow to get
water just let that sink in because you
can't fight is this you can't fight
city hall right so there you go all
right